talk to us about the payment bitcoin
feature that strike has rolled out how
does this work and why are people using
it it works just like a direct deposit
product is that when you line up your
paycheck you can go to jpmorgan chase
bank you could go to chime you could go
to strike and strike allows you to
toggle and convert any percentage of
your paycheck into bitcoin so that the
salary that you earn from working a wage
can be paid in half dollars half bitcoin
75 bitcoin 25 100 bitcoin and the point
in that is that saving accounts are dead
it costs more for a bank to custody your
dollars then they'll give you yield so
how do you save money and can you get
paid in commercial real estate can you
get paid in precious metal gold bars and
we wanted a product for the individual
consumer to say hey i want to save my
non-working capital in bitcoin because
it's the best savings technology of all
time
and that's it it's really dead simple
you hand your form to your employer and
uh from then on out for the rest of
eternity you can get paid in bitcoin
whatever percentage you want now mayor
you obviously got into a uh a little
competition a good competition in my
opinion where you said that you were
going to take your next paycheck in
bitcoin and then the mayor-elect in new
york city said oh yeah you're gonna do
one i'm gonna do three and then i think
you've come back over the top with i'm
gonna take all of my paychecks in
bitcoin so talk to us a little bit about
getting paid in bitcoin how you think
about it personally and then also the
potential to eventually do this with
other people within the city's uh
employee base
yeah so first of all you know a while
back uh you know i pledge that i wanted
to allow my employees to get paid in
bitcoin uh allow our
residents to be able to pay for fees and
taxes in bitcoin which we're still
working on and then eventually
potentially hold bitcoin on our balance
sheet so we've accomplished step one
already uh our cio mike saurasi was the
first uh city of miami employee to use
strike and to be able to get paid in
bitcoin um i i said you know what i'm
gonna i gotta follow him i gotta you
know it's uh like jack would say you
gotta lead by example and uh you know
and so i decided to do it and then of
course eric adams uh i think the mayor
of tampa uh the mayor of jacksonville uh
i think uh uh jack wilson is up to six
mayors already uh across the united
states are taking uh either all or some
or some percentage in bitcoin their
salaries you know when i started talking
about
a bitcoin in terms of uh you know in
terms of paying our employees a
percentage or whatever they want to like
like jack said it could be whatever
whatever they want right you know
bitcoin i think was like at 40 000. so
you know it's gone up 50
uh you know people talk a lot about the
volatility particularly people that
don't like bitcoin for whatever reason
they like to talk about the volatility
but they don't talk about the
year-over-year gains which is crazy i
don't understand how they can talk about
one thing without the other which is
really the more relevant statistic right
and so uh you know it's amazing and with
inflation certainly being underreported
as we all know um you know it's it's an
important hedge uh and it's becoming the
base currency for many many people
jack when you think about uh folks
getting paid in bitcoin this obviously
serves as a kind of a de facto uh dollar
cost averaging right every every week uh
every other week every month whenever i
get paid i'm just converting into
bitcoin talk a little bit about the
power of that and why that's so
important
yeah well first i didn't say happy
thanksgiving i'm on this show thankful
as [ __ ] right now the mayor the man and
the pomp brothers i hope everyone's
having a good holiday um
yeah all right so let's go on a little
bit of a rant
inflation
uh six percent according to cpi uh but
housing is my favorite metric um because
everyone needs a roof over their head to
live uh 24 and a half percent in the
united states so let me
put this abundantly clear and not in
word salad speak if you
watching this are not getting a 25
raise every single year
housing is getting more expensive than
you are earning income so you are not
making progress towards owning a home
okay
that's a huge problem how many of you
you family your friends are getting a 25
raise every single year to keep up with
how expensive housing is getting and so
are you [ __ ]
no you just cannot save in dollars
that's a very known thing whether it's
housing your kids education vacation
cars everything that's a hard asset
that's hard to obtain is getting more
expensive than you can earn so you have
to change the way you save and what's
very unique about bitcoin pomp is it's
the most accessible savings technology
of all time traditionally you'd have to
buy a big chunk of real estate you'd
have to find a way to store gold you
know maybe the ken griffins of the world
the big hedge fund managers maybe those
guys can go get new york city manhattan
penthouses and store their wealth there
what about me what about the mayor's
employees what about the everyday
individual is there an accessible scarce
uh monetary policy that's predictable
that lives external of any central party
that we can even get a penny of our
paycheck in and yes it's bitcoin and so
for me the whole power of the product is
that you don't need to convince your cfo
you don't need to work for a special
company you don't need to be a hedge
fund manager this is an asset that works
in the best interest of everybody it has
no bias it doesn't care towards any
certain type of wealth class it is the
most fair free open savings technology
in human history
and so all we're doing is letting you
line up your direct deposit and you get
to decide what portion of your savings
should be allocated towards bitcoin but
pom what if i tried to build a payment
gold bars product or a pay me in
commercial real estate product get the
[ __ ] out of here it'd be impossible that
things natively digi digital it's
divisible 100 million pieces you could
store it on your phone you could store
it for yourself it's an absolute
no-brainer and so we've got a dozen
mayors we've got nfl athletes we've got
the biggest musicians in the world but i
also have you want to know one of the
biggest companies of paycheck to our
service uber
you got guys that are trying to make a
living wage and outpace inflation and
work their way towards owning a home and
they're driving uber and an ability to
save to when the richest in the world
like michael saylor makes a buck the
uber driver makes a buck too and the
postmates delivery man right everyone is
in this together and so that it was so
intuitive to me of um let's just make
this as accessible as possible to the
people and allow them to outpace
inflation because inflation devastates
the poor more than the ken griffins in
the world it's really that simple